when I was 10 years old my parents took
me and my little brother to Vegas for my
birthday when I was a kid I was really
into magic and there was this
world-famous magician by the name of
Lance Burton who had a show at the Monte
Carlo Resort Casino my parents had
managed to get tickets for the night of
my birthday the show was absolutely
incredible
it started off with a bang and with each
consecutive trick it kept getting bigger
and better more outlandish more
incredible and the audience loved it and
then it came time for the climax of the
show Lance Burton came rolling out in a
bright red Corvette that was packed full
of showgirls and when I say this car was
packed folks showgirls I mean there were
so many showgirls in and around this car
you could barely tell it was a Corvette
so that's Burton came rolling out parked
the car right in middle of stage he got
out of the driver's seat walked in front
of it he took this long slow look at the
audience
and they came back to me and we locked
eyes and I was absolutely terrified
maybe even a little bit more terrified
than am right now this was one of my
heroes one of my idols from the best
magicians in the entire world and over
the past hour I had seen him do some of
the craziest tricks I've ever seen to be
honest with you at that point I wanted
nothing to do with him but he began to
tell me this story story about how when
he was my age his one wish his biggest
dream was to take a ride in a red
Corvette filled with showgirls and then
he asked me if that's what I wanted to
do tonight absolutely terrified
I remember I was gripping the sides of
my chair so tight I had white knuckles
and my jaw felt like it was clenched
shut after what felt like forever I
finally managed to eke out a very simple
answer his question remember going yeah
sure so he invites me up on the stage
and I remember I was bit huskier back
then but I got on my chair and I ran
over the sides they
quickest like been there was a showgirl
arm stretched out she grabs my hand she
brings him to Lance Lance puts me right
in the driver's seat of this bright red
Corvette all the showgirls piled back in
and the curtains go up and all of a
sudden lights go off and just as quick
as it had started it was all over the
lights came back on except this time I
was backstage and I remember looking out
from the car and seeing what seemed to
be miles and miles of props gadgets and
gizmos at lantry's than his show it was
a really incredible sight but something
that I know I'll never forget were these
television monitors that they had set up
all around the backstage that showed
what was going on up in front of the
stage from the audience's point of view
and we had gotten back there with just
enough time to see the reveal to the
audience that me and the showgirls in
the car had disappeared when that
curtain fell the audience went
absolutely crazy they loved it and I'll
never forget it because it was a really
strange feeling for me it was a strange
feeling of disconnectedness between what
I had just experienced and the story
that Lance was telling the audience and
this always stands out in my mind as an
excellent example of the power of
storytelling because the audience knew
that I didn't go on this magical car ID
and this Corvette filled with showgirls
I knew that it didn't happen that it
couldn't happen
but the story that Lance was telling and
the way in which he was doing it was so
powerful that they wanted to believe it
so it always stands out as that as a
perfect example of power storytelling
the ability to capture an audience's
attention motivate them and call them to
action now no person knows about the
true power of storytelling more than man
by the name of Peter Guber now Peter
Guber is a Hollywood executive a UCLA
professor and the chairman of Mandalay
Entertainment Group I came across a book
he had written called tell to win back
when I was an undergrad
and this book is entirely about the
power of storytelling in business and
I'll never forget the story the Peter
Guber uses to introduce his book it's a
perfect example of the critical
difference between data dumps and
purposeful stories so to tell that story
let's go back to Vegas except this time
instead of me it's Peter Guber and he's
sitting in the then mayor of Las Vegas
his office man by the name of mayor
Oscar Goodman and he's there to convince
the mayor that they should invest in a
brand-new state-of-the-art ballpark for
the minor league baseball team that man
will entertain me Group owned Peter
Guber remembers looking at each wall of
the office and recalling seeing
countless pieces of Hollywood
memorabilia what seemed to be an
unlimited amount of pictures of the
mayor with practically every star in
Hollywood everything about this guy
screamed major league when it came time
to start the presentation Peter Guber
began rattling off all the facts and
figures he had collected data point
after data point metric after metric all
the information about how mainly
entertainment was going to boost
revenues and cut costs and in the middle
of his one of his presentation the mayor
stopped him Denis trout's
he asked Peter Guber a very simple
question yeah soon can you bring a major
league baseball team to Las Vegas
now Peter Guber was a bit stunned at
this point he wasn't talking about
bringing the major league baseball team
in Las Vegas he was talking about
building a minor league ballpark so he
tried to rehash the same facts and
figures that he used before to try to
convince some errors but unfortunately
was unsuccessful the mayor never saw his
point eventually Manley entertainment
ended up selling the baseball team Peter
Guber looked back on this experience
later and tried to figure out what had
gone wrong then he realized that he'd
committed a fatal flaw even though he
was in the show business he had
forgotten to tell the mayor story when
he forgot to tell the mayor story he
lost some areas interest and we lost
mayor's interest he didn't have any
ability to motivate him the mayor never
saw the point that Peter Guber was
trying to make now this highlights the
crucial
difference between non stories and
purposeful stories you see non stories
like PowerPoint presentations filled
with all the facts and figures sure they
can convey information and sometimes
that's great
but there's nothing like a purposeful
story to move the hearts minds feet and
wallets of an audience in the speaker's
intended direction now luckily for us it
doesn't take much to tell a good story
or at least a decent one and only takes
three things and it's the same three
things that we've been using tell
stories since the beginning of humankind
and I'll give them to you tonight all we
need is one a challenge - a struggle to
overcome that challenge and three a
resolution that's it challenge struggle
resolution now let's go back to the
first story I told the one about me
disappearing on stage with Lance Berkman
I'm actually missing one of those I'm
missing the resolution some of you may
be disappointed find out that I did not
live out the rest of my life as a prop
in Lance Burton show did make it back to
see my family but we had to use my
reveal back to the audience as the
resolution his show much like I'm using
him as a resolution to my show tonight
the moment was just right Lance revealed
me and him sitting right in the middle
of the audience with a spotlight shining
brightly down on us and the audience
realized that we were there they
absolutely loved it Lance wasn't
finished quite yet he invited he invited
me back up on stage to give me a parting
gift can you so this was a shirt of me
and Lance Burton or it's picture of me
my turn with the shirt that I have even
to this day it's shirt that reminds me
to tell good stories sure the ones that
I love and encourage others around me to
do the same thank you very much